[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
nous sommes le lundi à 14 janvier tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
prendre de questions posées pour
encadrer le grand débat national
emmanuel macron a publié sa lettre aux
français
hier dans la presse et sur les réseaux
sociaux il y parle transition écologique
démocratie fiscalité et organisation de
l'état dans cette édition les réactions
des élus yvelines ont aidé et gilet
jaune locaux une quatrième édition
lancer une nouvelle job academy a
démarré ce matin au château de
versailles ce programme d'accompagnement
de retour à l'emploi est développé par
face kevin une collaboration de quatre
mois basée sur le partage des
compétences nous en parlons avec nos
invités
et puis les résultats sportifs du
week-end avec une première compliquée
pour les templiers d'elancourt une
victoire sur le fil contre les pionniers
de touraine pour débuter le championnat
de d2 de football américain chronique à
suivre invite également dans ce journal
virginie des lignes de la fondation des
amis de l'atelier l'association a ouvert
récemment son antenne à voisins le
bretonneux emmanuel macron a donc
diffusé sa lettre aux français dans la
soirée de dimanche un document dans
lequel il a développe les thématiques
qui vont occuper les français pendant le
grand débat national du 15 janvier au 15
mars et cela au travers de questions
posées pour lancer la réflexion est
maire gilet jaune et élusive linois les
réactions sont différentes à ce message
nicolas d'entrés elles étaient attendues
pour cadrer le grand débat national la
lettre du président de la république a
donné des détails sur son contenu
il se déroulera du 15 janvier au 15 mars
avec un rôle essentiel donnée au maire
et à ce titre que j'ai aussi j'ai aussi
décidé aujourd'hui puisqu'elle présente
plus que s'appuie sur les mers et c'est
une bonne chose si on peut contribuer
faire comprendre à l'état et aux
parlementaires que
les élus locaux en tout cas que la
décentralisation ou le renforcement de
leur compétence est important pour
justement faire en sorte de répondre aux
problématiques du quotidien de nos
habitants très bonne chose
quatre thématiques fiscalité et dépense
publique organisation de l'état
transition écologique et démocratie
précisant qu'il n'y aura pas de thème
interdite emmanuel macron ajoute
plusieurs questions quels impôts faut-il
à vos yeux baissés en priorité faut-il
renforcer la décentralisation et donner
plus de pouvoirs de décision et d'action
au plus près des citoyens
quelles propositions concrètes
feriez-vous pour accélérer notre
transition environnementale le plan je
pense que je suis vraiment dans le flou
aussi stratégique puisqu'elle être cette
lettre je pense que c'est une bonne
chose
voilà c'est un bon début maintenant je
suis assez sceptique qu'est ce qui va se
passer pendant ce débat est ce qu'on va
rester à attendre voilà et ensuite le
cnes qui en sortira j'attends de voir
évidemment il ya aussi l'urgence c'est
le pouvoir d'achat et là il ya des tas
de forme pour augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat
ça peut être une hausse des salaires ça
peut être aussi une baisse de la tva ou
voir la tva à taux zéro sur des produits
de première nécessité interrogation
aussi du côté de certains élus yves
binois comme la sénatrice sophie primas
sur les questions soulevées par le
président de la république et sur
l'organisation du débat comme le
conseiller départemental yves vandewalle
douteux sur la finalité dans les
yvelines le préfet a nommé un référent
aux grands débats l'instant aubert de
facilitateur et non d'organisateur
malgré ces quelques bugs vous pourrez
retrouver bien sûr ce reportage sur
notre site internet tv 78 points comme
une lettre de cadrage donc pour ce grand
débat national qui doit débuter demain à
la démarche repose bien entendu sur la
participation des citoyens avec des
réunions locales organisées allez-vous
il prendre par patrick jacques de
dixmude et aurélie rond sont allés vous
poser la question ça vous
on dit plus parler que ça en fait
j'avais ok vous m'annoncez manon c'est
un peu ça comme ça je suis pas du tout
au courant de ce débat je n'ai entendu
parler j'ai l'intention effectivement de
faire une proposition par internet
je ne pense pas avoir quoi que ce soit
comme revendication qu'ils puissent être
un minimum utile et je pense que dans
mon cas ce serait se serait pas une
forcément une voix suffisamment utile
pour faire avancer les choses
véritablement ah bah oui et c'est si
bien de faire ça sincèrement c'est bien
que ce que tu crois qu'il est à côté de
la plaque
donc laquelle qui va se j'espère qu'il
va en prendre coûte j'espérais c'est pas
tout faire d'après il faut qu'il en
prenne plein tiennent coûte bas j'ai pas
vraiment de point de vue en l'occurrence
je m'intéresse pas vraiment la politique
en ce moment j'ai d'autres aspirations
je me sens pas concerné le bourget 63
entendre que pour moi le monde politique
ne sera rien rien ne me sentir de ce
débat dans l'actualité une victime
yvelinoise dans le crash du mirage 2000
a dit la semaine dernière l'avion
militaire s'écrase et dans le jura
faisant deux morts on l'a appris en fin
de semaine dernière l'un des deux
membres d'équipage le lieutenant audrey
michelon était natif de saint germain en
laye sur twitter le maire de la ville
arnaud péricard a fait part de sa très
vive émotion et a rendu hommage à la
jeune officier ainsi qu'aux capitaines
chirier décédé également dans l'accident
une nouvelle édition la fondation face
yvelines a lancé ce matin la quatrième
édition de sa job academy avec le
château de versailles pour en parler
avec moi autour de la table deux invités
mohamed mansouri bonsoir ça avec le
directeur de fass yvelines et louis
samuel berger bonsoir bonsoir
administrateur général adjoint du
château de versailles en la job academy
c'est un programme d'accompagnement de
retour à l'emploi qui va durer quatre
mois un accompagnement viacess parrains
ou marraines qui vont épauler 16
filiales expliquez-nous moi même on
sourit le principe est pourquoi il est
intéressant ce principe de la job
academy
en fait le principe de la déjà votre
cadet mais il est assez simple mais il
repose effectivement sur une idée clef
qui est de pouvoir effectivement faire
rencontrer des demandeurs d'emploi donc
des personnes effectivement à la
recherche d'une activité professionnelle
avec des personnes en activité qui vont
apporter effectivement leurs compétences
leur expérience tout cela dans un
objectif commun qui effectivement de
retrouver une activité professionnelle
et donc le dispositif repose sur le
parrain et le filleul
et c'est ça qui est intéressant aussi
qui fait l'originalité du dispositif
exactement c'est vraiment cette richesse
à la fois dans l'accompagnement dans
l'expérience dans la transmission c'est
une notion effectivement relativement
importante et donc effectivement ça la
porte ça apporte beaucoup auprès du
filleul parce que ça lui permet
effectivement d'avoir une vision d'un
professionnel en activité et puis
effectivement une vision de compétences
qui vont nous permettre d'avancer dans
ses démarches de recherche d'emploi
et puis ça porte aussi également aux au
parrain et la marraine qui vont
effectivement donc transmettre justement
ces compétences et ce regard auprès du
fils côté château de versailles c'est la
quatrième fois donc que vous vous
associez à ce dispositif pourquoi
participer du coup à cette démarche de
la job academy
le château de versailles vous savez
c'est le haut lieu d'histoire que tous
les français connaissent mais c'est
aussi un acteur engagé dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas être
un grand acteur culturel sans prendre sa
part l'engagement social vous
découvrirez peut-être que le château de
versailles est un parmi les acteurs
culturels sans doute le premier en terme
d'emploi de travailleurs handicapés
et bien c'est dans la même logique que
nous travaillons avec la fondation agir
contre l'exclusion pour mettre à la
disposition des ans des personnes en
situation de recherche d'emploi
nos compétences nos équipes et
participer à leur insertion
professionnelle
on précise que c'est le seul
établissement culturel à participer au
programme job academy en france le
château de versailles c'est important
d'avoir ce partenaire culturel aussi
complètement ça permet effectivement de
diversifier déjà ses partenariats je
tiens vraiment à remercier les équipes
du château de versailles et le château
de versailles est effectivement de
s'impliquer sur cette opération qui est
là quand même la quatrième édition donc
c'est un partenariat qui s'inscrit
également dans dans la durée donc je
tiens vraiment effectivement à aller
remercier de cet engagement
et puis ça effectivement de pouvoir
s'appuyer justement sur un établissement
qui fait référence aujourd'hui dans le
monde culturel qui est effectivement le
château de versailles et de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur ces équipes qui sont
effectivement bas à disposition des
filleuls dans le cadre de leurs
démarches de recherche d'emploi sur le
profil des parrains et marraines ils
sont différents et hui direction du
château en tout sont représentés dans
cette promotion des métiers à techniques
comme administratif donc il ya vraiment
une variété de profils comment sont ils
choisissent et c'est eux qui font la
démarche de d'être d'être volontaires
pour ces job academy so lu ment ces
principes c'est la libre adhésion
évidemment des acteurs dans la démarche
est très vite
en fait ce sont les parrains de la laddh
l'édition précédente qui se retrouve
être les meilleurs ambassadeurs pour
engager leurs collègues a participé à
l'édition suivante il ya toujours
beaucoup de volontaires toujours
beaucoup de volontaires des gens qui
sont de milieu extrêmement différents
milieux professionnels extrêmement
différentes et avec toujours le même
souci finalement de développer autrement
ses compétences et finalement de
retrouver ce que nous sommes nous mêmes
c'est à dire un service public d'être au
service du public
alors ces binômes parent filles elles
sont constituées pour quatre mois comme
celui ci regarder les composé du chef du
service développement numérique du
château de versailles de ce demandeur
d'emploi en recherche depuis trois ans
et coûter leur motivation au micro de
marylène yapi chez nous
j'attends un contact avec une personne
qui est dans le pacte yves et dans
lequel dans le travail et qui peut me
donner des conseils bienveillants sur ma
sur ma démarche je pense que c'est
important d'être accompagné et où
d'avoir des personnes avec lesquelles on
peut échanger sur un sujet comme celui
là
parce que c'est important que les agents
d'un établissement public comme tel
public du château de versailles puisse
s'impliquer dans la vie locale et
sociale d'un territoire du département
est d'aider des personnes qui sont en
recherche d'emploi et je pense que quand
on recherche un travail c'est toujours
utile d'avoir un avis extérieur qu'ils
soient pas nécessairement celui des
proches de la famille et tout ce travail
je pense que quelqu'un qui est en poste
il a
cet état d'esprit qui permet peut-être à
des filleuls à des gens qui cherchent un
travail de l'aider et sur ce qui a été
dit vous allez me le confirmer c'est
finalement des deux côtés il ya un
intérêt à participer à ces job academy
fall fillol forcément qui va profiter de
l'expérience de son parrain pour
retourner vers l'emploi est le parrain
aussi sera enrichie de l'expérience oui
complètement effectivement les deux sont
gagnants c'est à dire la fois du côté du
filleul et puis effectivement la côte
est du du parrain ce qui ce qui
effectivement un des bénéfices que
souvent évoque les parent c'est
effectivement déjà cette notion de
transmission transmettre son expérience
transmettre son regard sa vision son
vécu effectivement dans ce dans un
objectif qui donne aussi du sens donc
c'est aussi fédérateur en interne de
trouver effectivement des des actions
des projets qui permettent à chacun de
trouver sa place effectivement de donner
dix ans aussi à sa mission et tout ça
portait effectivement par par par
l'établissement constitution des binômes
ce matin et premiers échanges ça va être
quoi le programme sur ces quatre mois
alors le programme est très clair
puisque effectivement il ya un planning
d'actions qui est très très défini donc
là effectivement il ya des rendez vous
individuels qui ont été calés donc
depuis depuis ce matin et puis ensuite
il ya des ateliers collectifs sont
également prévus et donc le premier
atelier a lieu le 28 janvier prochain
notamment sur la thématique du retour
sur l'image la côte et châteaux ses 50
personnes en tout qui ont été qui ont
été accompagnés grâce à ces job academy
on en est très fier mais c'est au delà
une vraie réussite pour l'ensemble de
l'institution puisque au delà de nos
alors d'abord c'est une vraie
progression puisque la première édition
c'était 8 parent aujourd'hui on en est à
mais au delà il ya un retour sur
l'ensemble de l'institution avec un
rayonnement parce que la réussite d'un
parent c'est la réussite d'une équipe
scénariste furent réussis d'une
direction et c'est la réussite d'une
institution toute entière donc c'est
vraiment tout bénéfice et je ne peux
qu'engagé d'autres institutions d'autres
entreprises à prendre contact avec la
fédération
la fondation pardon agir contre
l'exclusion pour engager d'autres job
academy
une dernière question elle est
importante ça marche le dispositif de la
job academy
oui en tout cas les résultats le
montrent en modestement parce
qu'effectivement nous on est là pour
être facilitateur dans cette danse est
mise en contact et dans cet objectif de
retrouver un emploi
mais globalement on a à peu près 70 à
80% de retour à l'emploi effectivement
sur 7 sur une durée de quatre mois
sachant qu' effectivement derrière on
peut mobiliser aussi de notre réseau
d'entreprise pour pouvoir se trouver des
solutions d'emploi auprès des personnes
merci à vous d'avoir été sur ce plateau
et on vous recevrez prochainement
mohamed montsouris pourrait évoquer les
20 ans de phase iib been puisque facile
une fête cette année son vingtième
anniversaire merci beaucoup inséré
réfléchir sur les liens entre la ville
et l'agriculture
saint-quentin-en-yvelines proposé jeudi
dernier une conférence sur ce thème
c'était à la médiathèque du canal de
montigny le bretonneux l'agglomération
souhaite mettre en place un plan
d'action pour développer un aménagement
durable plus de plus de détails avec ce
sujet d'aurélie ans
salle comble pour cette thématique
consacrée aux agricultures et aux
paysages de l'après pétrole
ce cycle de conférences intitulé agri et
urbain est organisée par la commération
saint-quentinoise le réseau des
médiathèques
il a débuté en décembre dernier ce
deuxième rendez vous avez pour objectif
de type sur les liens entre
l'agriculture et l'organisation de
l'espace
aujourd'hui les vins exploitation qui
ceux qui ont leur siège sur le
territoire sont dans des logiques de
questionnements de diversification de
mise en place de circuits courts et puis
de valorisation aussi de leur activité
et donc nous notre idée c'est de
vraiment de pouvoir faire cohabiter à
terme la ville avec ses espaces
agricoles et 2e des pièces techniques
pour qu'elles soient plus séparément
différentes formes d'agriculture qui
façonnent les paysages saint quentinois
parmi les intervenants un ingénieur
agronome et urbaniste au cours de la
soirée il a notamment abordé l'étude des
questions pratiques soulevé en matière
d'urbanisme et d'aménagement du
territoire
si on met en place une agriculture sans
intrants il va falloir qu'on retravaille
sûreté parfaite plus petit qu'on
réintègre l'arbre dans le système de
production va reprendre
un aspect plus désagréable plus
fréquentable à ses paysages qui
pourraient être utilisés par les
citadins les prochaines conférences
auront lieu les 14 mars et 16 mai
prochains
elles auront pour thème les circuits
courts alimentaires et l'agriculture
urbaine
elle est arrivée récemment à voisins le
bretonneux la fondation des amis de
l'atelier installé l'une de ses antennes
dans la vie la saint-quentinoise pour en
parler une nouvelle invitée virgin des
vignes virginie des vignes pardon
bonsoir vous êtes la directrice de la
plateforme interdépartemental 78 92 pour
la fondation l'antenne de voisins y est
rattachée alors déjà sur l'association
les reconnue d'utilité publique et elle
est au service des enfants et adultes en
situation de handicap de quelle manière
leur vient-elle en aide alors la
fondation est une fondation qui existe
depuis plus de 60 ans nous accompagnons
aujourd'hui aux environs de 2800 enfants
et adultes en situation de handicap
psychique mental ou avec autisme
d'accord nous avons deux mille huit
cents établissements sur l'ensemble de
l'île de france et dans le limousin
donc c'est des établissements des
services qui sont répartis sur le
territoire de sa fait soit des
institutions soient des services ouverts
pour accompagner à de l'inclusion et
comment ce fait cet accompagnement quel
type d'accompagnement vous apporter
alors c'est de l'accompagnement vers de
l'insertion professionnelle de
l'accompagnement vers de la
socialisation ou alors de l'hébergement
avec deux des institutions qui permet
d'accueillir au long terme des personnes
en situation de handicap
l'idée de la fondation c'est d'apporter
une réponse personnalisée à chaque
enfant chaque chaque adulte
oui majoritairement on essaye
effectivement selon le type de handicap
de pouvoir les accompagner du mieux
possible avec des personnes formées à
chaque type de handicap
non je dis vous êtes la directrice de la
plateforme interdépartemental sur les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine pour pour
la fondation
expliquez-nous quelles sont les missions
de cette plateforme est pourquoi elle a
été mise en place sur ces deux
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine alors c'est le premier
appel à projets inter départementale qui
a été créée entre le département des
hauts-de-seine et des yvelines
c'est un appel à projets auxquels la
fondation a répondu au mois de mai 2010
est qu'ils étaient lancés par les
conseils départementaux et les haches
ans
chenal de santé nous avons remporté la
fondation a remporté ce concours en
décembre 2017
cette plateforme comprend une partie
hébergement avec un foyer d'accueil
médicalisé qui ouvrira en décembre 2020
ou janvier 2021 qui sera situé aux
mureaux avec 116 places d'accueil
permanent donc en hébergement et lors de
cet appel à projets les tutelles nous
ont demandé de faire une ouverture
anticipée des services ambulatoires qui
comprend un samsa donc un service
d'accompagnement pour des personnes à
domicile et 2 p cpe qui sont des
nouveaux dispositifs de l' agence
régionale de santé 1 sur le 78 sur le 92
vous parlez des samsa justement pour
présenter l'antenne de
voisins-le-bretonneux on y retrouve deux
services notamment le samsah qui est
lady le service d'accompagnement
médico-social pour les adultes
handicapés de quoi s'agit-il
alors il s'agit d'accompagner des
personnes qui sont encore à domicile ou
en résidence autonome
ce sont des personnes avec autisme haut
niveau qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement soit vers de l'emploi en
milieu protégé ou en milieu ordinaire
soit vers de l'autonomisation dans les
transports dans la vie sociale pour
pouvoir les aider à les inclure donc ça
c'est pour le sable ça qui est premier
service proposé à voisins on nous
retrouver un autre c'est le pcp le pool
de compétences et de prestations
externalisées tout à fait qui accompagne
un autre type de public
là c'est vraiment enfants et adultes se
sont toutes les personnes qui se
retrouvent à domicile sans aucune
solution où on propose de coordonner
avec la mdph donc la maison du handicap
ou la mda sur les yvelines de coordonner
l'ensemble des intervenants libéraux
auprès des personnes seules à domicile
pour aider les familles et ces deux
services amsa et bcp sont d'ores et déjà
disponibles sur sur cette antenne de
voisins-le-bretonneux tout à fait le
samsah ouvert ses portes le 3 décembre
et le pcp eux le 2 janvier puisqu'on
peut venir vous rencontrer sur sur place
sur cette antenne de voisins tout à fait
les équipes sont déjà sur place donc y'a
pas de soucis et le site et est affichée
pour avoir plus d'information merci
virginie des lignes d'avoir été avec
nous
à vous je rappelle que vous êtes la
directrice de la plateforme
interdépartemental 78 92 pour la
fondation des amis de l'atelier mélanie
poker nous a rejoints plateau bonsoir ça
alors les cérémonies de voeux continue
sur saint quentin en yvelines vendredi
soir c'était au tour de grégory à gary
astier de s'adresser à ses administrés
le maire de maurepas a notamment choisi
de rapprocher la ville de l'emploi et
des commerces
eh oui maurepas et coignard ont été
retenus grâce au soutien de saint
quentin en yvelines pour restructurer la
zone d'activités paris-ouest forum du jv
et porte de chevreuse il s'agira de
trouver des complémentarités entre ces
zones où des logements vont être
construits mais je laisse grégory gary
style nous expliquer concrètement l'état
va nous aider financièrement hauteur de
60 mille euros à financer un assistant
maîtrise d'ouvragé qui va nous faire des
scénarios opérationnels pour calibrer
dans le futur ce que sera ce futur
ensemble de la zone d'activités paris
ouest avec une partie de coignières
l'objectif c'est de trouver davantage
d'articulation de cohérence d'intégrer
davantage de logements et aussi de
traiter une partie de la zone
sûrement pas qui est moribonde
aujourd'hui et grigori guy ritchie a
donné aussi d'autres grandes lignes
autour de l'urbanisme
et oui vendredi soir et gorée le maire a
annoncé aussi que le nouveau plan local
d'urbanisme serait votée avant l'été
pour préserver les ovales de
l'urbanisation le village et ses terres
agricoles pas moins de 1000 logements
seront construits dans les quatre ans à
venir
et c'était l'une des toutes premières
annonces de cette soirée
le centre nautique d'elancourt mort par
ouvrira en 2021
rappelons que le site a été fermé en
avril 2015
grégory gare et s'ils avaient alors pris
à cette époque un arrêté municipal
d'urgence la déconstruction du site
actuel débutera cette année
merci mélanie on continuera dans ce
journal de faire d'autres pans sur les
cérémonies de voeux qui se déroule dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
la ville de poissy elle présentera ses
voeux à la population ce mercredi en
attendant le maire karl olive a réuni la
presse pour présenter les grands temps
forts de 2010 9 l année sera marquée par
le début des travaux du futur centre
d'entraînement du paris saint germain
un site de 74 hectares le club va
quitter son fief historique de saint
germain en laye autre projet la création
du
musée le corbusier est aussi l'avancée
de certains dossiers en matière de
transports les propos recueillis par
nickel et demi d'euros
concernant le rer eole on poursuit les
neuf nouvelles gares qui viendront
jusqu'à poissy depuis depuis menthe
déclaration d'utilité publique pour le
tramway le tram 13 qui est à moi un
élément fondamental pour le devenir de
de poissy et puis également du travail
sur la poursuite des navettes des
navettes bleus pour pour les seniors et
pourquoi pas des navettes blanche pour
pour l'hôpital et plus tard pour le
paris saint-germain
[Musique]
c'est devenu une tradition le lundi
c'est le genre de la chronique sport
bonsoir a indiqué l'ennemi d'euros ont
servi à gori c'est toujours un plaisir
de revenir ici on essaie pour moi
légalement alors vous venez sur ce
plateau pour nous présenter les
principaux résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département il y en a
beaucoup et on commence par du football
américain
c'était la reprise pour les templiers
d'elancourt et ils ont dû s'employer ce
samedi soir pour remporter leur première
victoire de la saison dans le
championnat de 2e division
les footballeurs saint quentinois ont
réussi à battre les pionniers de
touraine à domicile dans le money time
dans les toutes dernières minutes
score final avec 14 à 13 en écoute les
réactions au micro de tv 78
la victoire est toujours mérité on sait
on s'est battu pour un pour aller la
chercher
on était mené tout le match on est parti
le chercher sur dernier drive et au
final on a juste marqué un point de plus
que les autres ce qu'il fallait faire
victoire méritée puisque toute façon du
corse
c'est bon à prendre après la manière
n'est pas forcément là mais il faut dire
que les tempes ils se sont fait très
peur grégory eux qui espéraient passer
une soirée tranquille à la mi temps ils
étaient menés à 6 à 0 sur le terrain
face à ces pionniers pionniers de
touraine
les explications avec le joueur david
pradel premier match de saison on
connaît pas les équipes en face on n'a
pas eu le temps de les voir voir ce
qu'ils vont voir leur club ou qu on n'a
rien vu de la saison donc forcément le
temps d'adaptation on a un jeune cube et
donc forcément il fallait qu'il prenne
fallait qu'elle prenne ses marques
les templiers devront trouver leurs
marques rapidement les footballeurs se
déplaceront sur le terrain des diables
rouges de villepinte ce samedi 19
janvier mais qui prétend également est
montée en fin de saison et après le
football américain on passe à un autre
sport de contact qui ressemble aussi au
foot eu à cesser le rugby d'en rigoler
on prend la direction de versailles
rien n'arrête versailles les hommes de
la cité royale ont remporté une 10e
victoire consécutive ce dimanche 13
janvier leur victime du jour monter son
deuxième du classement les versets ils
ont emporté 16 à 5
mais cette fois ci sans panache une
réaction au micro de manon varaldo les
autres aussi sont claires c'est à dire
que nous on veut rien lâcher
on va essayer de gagner tous nos matches
comme on fait tous les tous les
week-ends
le bus devait être aussi docile intégré
pas mal de joueurs comme on l'a fait
avec des rotations pour tout le monde
puisse goûter la belle aventure est
bien évidemment on essaie d'aller le
plus loin possible après avec cette
victoire les versailles et compte douze
unités d'avancé sur leur dauphin
montesson après dix journées disputées
même si la montée en fédérale 3 semble
se dessiner pour versailles on va voir
la classe ont justement grégory
versailles 46 points à montesson 34
points le staff veut continuer à
engranger des points et on a pas on n'a
pas lu l'interview malheureusement
michael mais c'est pas grave on pourra
peut-être la retrouver dans votre set
correctement en tout cas pour continuer
sa série d'invincibilité versa il se
rendra sur le terrain de gif-sur-yvette
le huitième du classement ce dimanche 20
janvier je note ce rendez vous car c'est
à côté de chez moi dans l'essonne mikel
pour votre 7,8 sport quel est le
programme quelle est la suite du
programme aura forcément des templiers
d'elancourt du rc versailles qui a
remporté également une très belle
victoire ce week-end et on parlera de
paris-nice la constituante qui passera
par les villes par les yvelines un
départ de saint-germain-en-laye saint
germain en laye et deuxième étapes
depuis les bréviaires merci michael et
le 7-8 sport bien sûr c'est à retrouver
juste après ce journal d'ailleurs c'est
la fin de ce journal est le replay est à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 belle
soirée à tous
[Musique]